heavenly father again I just pray for
your holy spirit to guide us through
this next session father to keep us
alert keep us awake
illuminate our minds by your Holy Spirit
help us to grasp these Eternal truths we
ask it in Jesus name amen
I'm not I don't know how I'm going to go
through this I may not hit all the texts
in here I may just hit enough that you
get the sense of what we're talking
about because you have the notes
what we're going to talk about here is
the law the prophets and the Advent
movements we're going to look at
besides Revelation 12 17 well why don't
we open there let's go to Revelation 12
17.
you know there are a few texts that we
usually look at
um
that direct us to look for a last day
profit but we're going to go through a
whole series of texts today that I think
will establish this more clearly
Revelation chapter 19 19 12 and verse
17. sorry
Revelation 12 17.
foreign
and the Bible tells us here
the dragon was Wrath with the woman
just means enraged hostile some of your
translations will say
and he went to make war with the rest of
her Offspring who keep the Commandments
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
now we traced through Revelation 12 and
we see that this is a picture of the
church the crit the birth of the
Christian church as Christ is the the
Christ child is born he's taken up to
heaven then the church is goes into the
Wilderness comes out on the other side
of the Wilderness in 1798 and brings us
right up to our day and focus Us in on a
church that keeps guide God's
Commandments and has the gift of
Prophecy and of course we this is
something that's familiar to us but it
will be more familiar as we go through a
little bit here
this just tells us that God's Remnant
Church
The Remnant the rest The Offspring of
the woman
will be keeping the Commandments of God
and
they'll have the gift of Prophecy
uh one a says there is deep significance
to this text especially in these two
characteristics the law and the prophets
this is not the only text that has the
law and the prophet says as combined
together and you're going to see that as
we go these two go hand in hand this
theme is consistent throughout the
scripture we are going to look at a few
texts to establish this now before I
even go further why would you think that
the law and the prophets would go
together
based on our last study
okay because the prophets get what
that's not what I'm looking for why do
you think the law and the prophets would
go together
well let's go through let's go through
some of the texts I think
it'll you'll get some ideas as we go
through let's start
in Psalm 78 and verse 5.
and we're going to go through these kind
of quickly
you know we're not I'm not going through
and doing a big contextual study on each
text I want you to get just this link
between the law and the prophets
Psalm 78 and verse 5. who wants to read
that for me
Psalm 70 5 Josh read that please
okay now we don't think a lot about that
we've Read that read that text before
but I just want you to notice the how
the law and the prophets go together in
that a testimony what's a testimony it's
a testimony of Jesus the spirit of
Prophecy there's the testimony in the
law God established a testimony in the
law acts 24 14 who wants to do that one
for me
okay Ezekiel acts 24 14.
that important to the way would they
call a set so I worship the god of my
fathers believing all things which are
written in the law and in the prophet
okay once again you probably read these
things before and thought law in the
prophet's well you know it's just we I
don't think we think much about it but I
just want you to see the connection
between the two through the scriptures
Isaiah 8. 16 and 20. you're familiar
with this one more with 20 than maybe
verse 16. I want you to catch verse 16.
who wants to read Isaiah 8 16 and 20.
Okay Kevin
or I mean Stephen
okay verse 16 bind up the testimony seal
the law always have the two together to
the law and to the testimony
you see the connection there between the
two Isaiah 30
and verse 9 and 10. who wants to read
Isaiah 30 verses 9 and 10.
Vesta
I'll get you next Kevin
Isaiah 30 verses 9 and 10.
prophesy illusions
okay now notice something here they will
not hear the what
they will not hear it says in verse 9 uh
they will not hear the law children who
will not hear the law of the Lord
and then what do they say to the
prophets
don't
don't prophesy now why would you imagine
that
that's the case based on our last study
say that again
okay something else why why the
connection
they're saying it says here in again in
verse 9 that the children won't hear the
law of the Lord and they're saying to
the prophets do not what do not prophesy
okay
what what connection are you are you
picking up a connection there
if a person isn't wanting to hear the
law are they going to want to hear the
prophet
it's just like we were talking about in
the last session right the whole
authority issue if you're not wanting
the law you're not going to want the
profit
what good is it God what good will it do
God to send a prophet to people who
won't hear the law
you're not going to hear the voice of
God's Authority is a law authoritative
it's God's Authority in his law then if
you're if you reject the law you're
rejecting what
Authority and if you rejected in the law
you're going to reject it in the prophet
you're going to reject it in Christ
himself
right you follow that so we see this
connection here and Proverbs 28 9 18 we
looked at the other day we won't go to
it now
where there is no vision the Bible said
the people perish but then the contrast
but happy is he who keeps the law
so now you have a contrast where there
is no vision
the people perish but happy is he who
keeps the law
where there is no vision there's nobody
happy about keeping the law evidently
but happy is he who keeps the law the
law and the prophets once again go
together
however God's people rebelled against
the law and the prophets Nehemiah 9 26
go there with me Nehemiah 9 26
I didn't have you read yet did I Kevin
Nehemiah 9 26 want to read that for us
Nehemiah 9 26.
they were disobedient
that's on your law behind their backs
and killed your prophets who warned them
to turn back to you
committed terrible glasses okay that's
an interesting passage there first they
rebelled against God
well obviously then they rebelled
against God and what they do with his
law
cast it away cast it behind their backs
what do you do with their what they do
with their profits kill the prophets
once you've rejected the authority of
God you're not going to go and say yeah
I reject God but yeah give me the law
and the prophets
so you've got the connection between the
law and the prophets okay God's people
rebelled against the law and against the
prophets also in Jeremiah 18 18 who
would like to read Jeremiah 18 18 for us
I know we're going to kind of going
quick we'll slow down in a moment
Jeremiah 18 18.
if I were to give a bible study on this
I wouldn't necessarily give all the
texts that I'm giving I want you to see
the consistency through the scripture
but I could have we could have we could
have gone Isaiah 8 20 and said the law
and the testimony we could have gone a
couple texts and seen the law and the
prophets but I just want you to see this
consistent theme through scripture
because it's going to come to play
um
Jeremiah what do we say 18 and verse 18
Angela
okay now this is an interesting text
it's going to contrast our next one they
said come let us devise plans against
the prophet
why they said for the law shall what
not perish from the priest nor the
counsel from the wise nor the word from
the prophet
we see the law and the prophets but here
they say we can reject Jeremiah and we
can still maintain the law
the law is not going to perish neither
is the vision going to perish among our
people we reject Jeremiah's prophecy
so they maintain even in their Rebellion
that uh God's not going to depart from
us
number four God warned that their
Apostle their apostasy would not go
unpunished if they continued to reject
his law he would remove the prophetic
Ministry from their midst and leave them
to the delusions which they had chosen
we see that in Ezekiel 7 26 they said
the law is not going to perish from
among the priests well let's see what it
says in Ezekiel Ezekiel 7
Ezekiel you want to read that
Ezekiel 7 and verse 26 seems only
fitting
Ezekiel 7 and verse 26. disaster will
come up on disaster and rumor upon ruler
then they will seek a vision from a
prophet but the law will perish from the
priests and the council formalde okay
they will seek a vision but the law is
going to perish why because they've
turned their back on the prophets they
turn their back on the law the god the
law and the prophets go together
when you get the law you get the profits
when you turn on the law you've you've
lost the gift of Prophecy
right you you and I can't maintain the
prophetic gift can we
God gives the gift God can take the gift
away
oh I've got a real interesting uh
something I need to share with you on
that
but not just yet Zechariah 7.
let's go to the book of Zechariah
Chapter 7 and verses 10 to 13 who would
like to read that for me Zechariah 10
7 to 13.
all right Daniel
Zechariah 10 I'll get you next Jack
Zechariah 10 7-13
7 10-13 thank you
I just want to make sure you're all
paying attention
the Zechariah 7
10 to 13. go ahead Daniel
just as he called and they would not
listen so they called and I would not
listen says the Lord
Justice says what did he say there he
just as he proclaimed and they would not
listen they would not hear so they
called out and I would not listen said
to the Lord they wouldn't listen to me
I'm not listening to them
they rejected the law and I'm not giving
them the prophetic Ministry the law and
the prophets are gone from God's people
and Lamentations 2 8 9 is one of the oh
Proverbs 28 9.
you've seen this one before Proverbs 28
verse 9 Jack I'm going to have you read
that one for us Proverbs 28
and verse 9.
one who turns away his ear from hearing
the law even his prayer is an
abomination
you pray to the Lord and say Lord I need
help this and that and then you yep then
the Lord says okay well why don't you
walk like Scott was talking about last
night the choices we make
however we sometimes we expect God to do
something for us and God says I ask you
to walk in this pathway you're walking
over here and you're expecting the
results that you would have only in this
pathway
You're Expecting the scenery
that you would get in this path walking
over here on this path
Lord says it's not going to happen he
who turns his ear from hearing the law
of the Lord even his prayers and
Abomination you're turning away from God
God's not going to send you uh God's not
going to hear your prayer God's not
going to send you a prophet
if you are willfully rejecting him
you follow that
and the last one there Lamentations two
eight and nine
Lamentations to
who wants to read Lamentations two eight
and nine for me
okay
tell me your name again please Sarah
that's right
Lamentations two eight and nine
we have destroyed and broken her bars
her Kings and her principles are among
the Gentiles the law is no more and her
profits also by no vision from the Lord
the law is no more and the prophets find
no vision from the Lord
here's the point it says down there the
law and the prophets go what
they go together those who refuse to
obey God's laws who refuse to heed the
voice of His prophets those who rejected
His prophets also rejected his law
regardless of their profession
because of the Rebellion God removed the
law and the prophets from his people
I don't necessarily want to say he would
remove the law the law was still
expected that they were to keep it but
just basing on what Lamentations there
said
yet the Lord did not leave his people
alone he promised that if obedient he
would restore the prophetic gift to his
church let's look at it in Malachi 3.
Malachi is the last book of the Old
Testament
right before the 400-year drought
of a prophetic gift of a prophetic voice
God spoke through Malachi
and the last words of Malachi the last
words of the last book of the Old
Testament Malachi 4 starting in verse 4.
who wants to read this
okay
oh hold on a minute now
I was just I just mentioned your name
again this morning and now I'm thinking
is it is it Craig yeah
I was thinking Craig and I thought
that's not right okay thank you Craig
I'm going to have you read Malachi 4
verses 4 through 6.
for all Israel with the statutes and
judgments behold I will send you Elijah
the prophet before the coming of the
great and Dreadful day of the Lord and
he shall turn the hearts of the fathers
to the children and the hearts to the
children to the fathers lest I come and
smite the Earth with curse okay
it says behold I send you you know first
he says remember the law of Moses my
servant
and I will send you Elijah the prophet
you got the law and the prophets and
here you have a promise by the Lord who
you know Malachi like I said there's 400
years with no prophetic voice
before we reach into we come into the
Book of Matthew and yet here the Lord
tells his people who had been taken it
gone to foreign lands and of course
they'd been
um they had rejected the Lord they'd
rebelled they'd gone through a lot of uh
discouraging experiences but the Lord
tells them remember the law of Moses my
servant
in essence and I will send you Elijah
the prophet before the coming of the
great and Dreadful day of the Lord
incidentally that little Pat that little
phrase the coming of the great and
Dreadful day the Lord is only two places
in the Bible
um in in the Old Testament scriptures I
should say well it doesn't word it that
way in the New Testament scriptures you
know where it isn't elsewhere else in
the Old Testament you find that great
and Dreadful day the Lord
no
another one
a prophecy that talks about the great
and Dreadful day of the Lord and
incidentally it also has to do with
Prophets
your sons and daughters
Joel chapter 2 and also well let's go on
here
so God has a promise to his people even
in the in the midst of all this that if
you seek the law I will restore to you
the prophet
notice verse chapter 3 and verse 1.
he says in chapter 3 and verse 1 behold
I send my what
messenger and he will prepare the way
before me and carrying on with that
whole train of thought you'll see why
we're doing this we finish up there
where he says remember the law of Moses
my servant behold I send you Elijah the
prophet that Elijah the prophet is the
messenger he's speaking about right
there in chapter 3 verse 1.
then we're going to see how Jesus
supplies it when we get to the New
Testament so God leaves a promise at the
end of the Old Testament Canon that says
you can return to me and I'll return to
you you return to my law I'll restore to
you the gift of Prophecy now let's go to
Matthew 11. we were in Luke 7 earlier
and I told you it was a parallel with
Matthew 11 now we're in Matthew 11.
Matthew 11 verse 7.
and the Bible says as they departed
Jesus began to say to the multitudes
concerning who
John John the Baptist now this is
parallel we're not going to read through
all the details here we looked at that a
little bit earlier but notice he's
saying these things in regard to John
and he says in verse 10 notice what it
says for this is he of whom it is
written behold I send my what
messenger before your face will prepare
your way before you where do we just
read that Malachi chapter 3 verse 1.
Jesus says this is he
John the Baptist he's the one
he's talking to them concerning John you
follow me with that this is the
messenger that will prepare the way
uh and then verse 13 and 14. notice what
he says of John for all the prophets in
the law prophesied until John and if you
are willing to receive it he is what
Elijah who is to come where do we just
read about the coming Elijah
we read it in Malachi
John 1 21 and through 23 I'm not going
to go there but in John 1 21 is when the
people came they asked John the Baptist
John are you are you Elijah you ever
wonder about that when they came up to
John they said are you Elijah he thought
what in the world are you Elijah
has anybody ever wondered that when you
read through John Juan what do you you
know these guys are crazy are you Elijah
of course I'm not Elijah I'm John the
Baptist
where have you been
okay but that's why they're asking him
the question they remember the prophecy
of Malachi they haven't seen a prophet
and here comes John the Baptist and they
recognize this man is speaking with
authority are you the one
that's what they're asking are you
Elijah John says no I'm not Elijah
oh you know John's just basically saying
no I'm not Elijah I'm John
you know
was Jesus saying that Elijah was going
to be resurrected and come back
no
Jesus says that took place before this
Jesus says here he is the Elijah who is
to come
he who has ears to hear Let Him hear if
you are willing to receive it he says
this is the one I spoke of if you are
willingness those are heavy words if
you're willing to receive it this is
Elijah who was to come
and notice verse
28 of Matthew 11.
Jesus says there
oh no I'm in the wrong spot
is it in John I don't think it's in John
1. I've got my I've got the wrong text
there we just read about it in Luke that
John was the the greatest of the
prophets in verse 11 it says surely I
say to you among those born of women
that has not risen one greater than John
the Baptist but he was least in the
Kingdom of Heaven is greater than he
let's look at John 1. wondering if I'm
missing something here
no
so that that's but
no I'm beyond that I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna hold up on it you you've we've
seen the text already it's in in essence
it's uh what verse 11 says
oh no that's not what I'm looking for
I'm looking for verse nine
what did he say there Matthew 11 verse 9
what did you go out to see a prophet yes
I say to you what
more than a prophet and then verse 11
surely among women there's risen no
greater than John the Baptist so notice
John the Baptist was the Elijah to come
Jesus said he was more than a prophet
he was a messenger
and he was the greatest of the prophets
you follow that why was he the greatest
why would Jesus say something like that
he's the greatest of the prophets what
made his prophetic Ministry so great
he prepared the way for Christ those who
received John receive Jesus you know so
what what a privilege and an honor that
John had
that he was to prepare the way for the
coming of Christ
however
letter A John
was only a partial fulfillment
just as Pentecost was a partial
fulfillment in the prophecy of Joel The
Great and Dreadful day of the Lord was
still yet to come
and there's some texts to talk about the
coming of the
great and Dreadful day of the Lord not
quite in that language Joel
and Malachi had foretold it
look at B the prophet John was the
connecting link between the two
dispensations
as God's representative he stood forth
this is quoting From Desire of Ages page
220 the prophet John was the connecting
link between the two dispensations is
God's representative he stood forth to
show the relation of the law and the
prophets to the Christian dispensation
next sentence he was the what
he was the Lesser light which was to be
followed by a greater
John was
more than a prophet
he was the Elijah to come
he was a messenger
he was a lesser light leading to the
greater light
you follow that
he was a partial fulfillment
the mind of John had been illuminated
was illuminated this is now she explains
lesser light and greater light right
here the mind of John was illuminated by
the holy spirit that he might shed light
upon his people but no other light has
ever shown or ever will shine so clearly
upon Fallen man as that which emanated
from the teaching and example of Jesus
there's the greater light in this verse
John is just a reflection
now I want you to divert from that what
we've got so far is we've got the Bible
telling us that the law and the prophets
have gone together we see these things
going together when God's people were
faithful to follow him to obey him God
privileged them with the gift of
Prophecy but when God's people had
turned their back upon his law neither
did they have the prophetic gift not to
say that they never I mean obviously
with God's people had turned their back
on the law God used prophets to try to
direct them but when they just rejected
completely the prophetic gift was
removed the law and the prophets went
together you see that
but God promises in the end of the Old
Testament that if you return to me I'll
return to you remember the law of Moses
my servant behold I send Elijah the
prophet we come to the New Testament
you've got people Jesus John the Baptist
is preaching people are coming under
repentance they come and to be baptized
of John and Jesus as he's talking about
John the Baptist says this is the one I
told you about
he's the Elijah that was to come if
you're willing to receive it
now I'm going to divert a little bit to
Daniel chapter eight okay
Daniel 8 we're going to Daniel 8 and
verse 9.
Daniel 8
and verse 9.
and following that's what that f is
Daniel 8 verse 9 and following I want
you to follow what's being said here
we're not getting into all the detail of
this I'm going to come back at the end
of the month and we're going to talk
about Daniel 7 8-9
but Daniel 8 and verse 9 I want you to
read there start there with me
speaking of the four Horn uh Four Winds
of Heaven which we'll talk more about
later out of one of them came a little
horn which grew exceedingly to the uh
exceedingly great toward the South
toward the East and toward the Glorious
land and the speaking of the Antichrist
power the rise of the Antichrist notice
verse 10 it grew up to the host of
heaven and it cast down some of the
hosts and some of the Stars to the
ground and what
trampled them he even exalted himself as
what
as high as the prince of the host and by
him the daily sacrifices were taken away
and the place of his Sanctuary was cast
down that daily sacrifices refers
sacrifices as a supplied word that
refers primarily to the ministry of
Christ the ministry of Christ was
perverted by this Antichrist power the
place of his Sanctuary was cast down
because of transgression an army was
given over to the horn to oppose the
daily sacrifices and he cast what
what did he cast down he cast truth to
the ground and he did all this and he
prospered now that's our setting I'm
going to ask you some questions on it in
a moment but basically you've got the
Antichrist power that's distorting the
ministry of Christ and he's casting down
the truth to the ground and he's
prospering while he does it
Daniel's watching all this Daniel is so
stupefied he doesn't even know what to
ask he doesn't ask the question one Holy
One asks another holy quote one in verse
13. then I heard a Holy One speaking and
another Holy One said to the one that
was speaking how long will the vision be
concerning the daily sacrifices and the
transgression of desperation desolation
the giving of both the sanctuary and the
host to be trampled underfoot and he
said to me for 2 300 days then shall the
sanctuary be cleansed
question what did this Antichrist power
do again
okay let's focus on that piece of it he
cast truth to the ground tell me some
ways that the Antichrist Powers cast
truth to the ground
we're looking back on it now you ought
to be able to tell me something
as well okay the Sabbath the issue of
the Sabbath distorted through the Dark
Ages right by men's Traditions heaped up
over top of it Etc what else has been
distorted
huh
okay but let's let's come into we're
this is in the Christian realm the
Antichrist is within Christianity how in
Christianity has the Antichrist Castro
to the ground
okay forgiveness of sin going to man for
the Forgiveness of sins how else
okay casting down to the word of God
what are some specifics
where in the world do we get this idea
that people burn forever and ever in
hell
where did it start
I mean obviously it was in paganism how
to get into Christianity to the Dark
Ages truth was cast to the ground right
okay what else
the modes of baptism all these Pagan the
immortality of the Soul all these Pagan
Concepts were brought in and Truth was
cast to the ground and this power
prospered and the question is asked how
long will it be how long will truth be
cast down that's what Daniel was asking
that's what I would have been asking how
long under 2 300 days when did that time
period end
we're going to spend more time on it
you've gone through it 1844 A.D
and what that essentially says is the
question how long how long will the
vision be how long will truth be cast
down until
1844 A.D
and then we're going to see a movement
arise
to restore
the truth of God
you follow that
that's what the prophecy is telling us
we're going to plug this into what we
looked at already in just a minute but
Daniel 7 25 the power would think to
change times and law there's something
that was cast down to the ground the big
issue and we're going to see that from
in fact right there from great
controversy
page 80 uh oh that's the 88 1888 version
I didn't notice that when I got it great
controversy 1888 version 1911 was the
most recent we have uh page 64. as
foretold by prophecy it's in both by the
way as foretold by prophecy the papal
power cast down truth to the ground the
law of God was trampled in the dust
while the traditions and customs of men
all these other doctrinal
things
while the traditions and customs of men
were exalted
Revelation 12
verse 6.
Revelation 12 verse 6.
you have a picture of this church
the Bible says the woman fled Into the
Wilderness where she has a place
prepared by God that they should nourish
her there feed her there for one
thousand two hundred sixty days
that period
and I'm not covering this now hopefully
it has been or will be 5 38 to 1798 A.D
that period ended
when Pope vigilius was taken captive
who was telling me the other day what
pope was that
what Pius VI
Pope vigilius was captured and died in
Exile
it says this woman would be nourished
this church would be nourished until
1798 after 1798 that church is going to
resurface
and when we see that church resurfacing
the Bible tells us in verse 16 the Earth
helped the woman how did the Earth help
that church
swallowed up the water how how did the
Earth help the church what's the
Fulfillment of that does anybody know
yeah the church was in the wilderness he
was persecuted God prepared a place in
the wilderness where she could hide
and then the dragon spewed out this
flood
verse 15 the serpent spewed water out of
his mouth like a flood after the woman
that he might cause her to be carried
away with a flood but the Earth helped
the woman
and it says the Earth opened its mouth
and swallowed up the flood out of the
drag which the dragon is spewed out of
his mouth how would the Earth helped the
woman
populated area
an unpopulated area right Revelation 13
I saw another Beast rising up where
out of the Earth
how the Earth helped the woman God rose
up this country the United States of
America a place of religious freedom
where that woman fled
and we see that woman coming to this
free land and in verse 17 the dragon was
enraged with a woman and went to make
war with the rest of her Offspring who
keep the Commandments of God the law
and have the what
the prophets
so now we have a prophecy at the end of
the 2300 days truth is going to be
restored one of those things that was
cast down was the law of God right
Ellen White just said it in Great
controversy the Bible tells us in Daniel
7 25. right he's gonna
change times and laws think to change
times and laws
but the Bible tells us here there's
going to be a faithful church at the end
of time after 1798 that rises up that's
going to be
keeping the law of God
and God will restore to that church the
testimony
you follow that
look at the statement there underneath
oh no no no that's not what I want
about halfway down on the bottom of page
two it says
that the two witnesses would prophesy in
sackcloth and Ashes at the end of the
2300 days it was prophesied that the
Fallen truth would be restored
God prepared a way for the woman to come
out into a new land to restore the truth
that had been systematically dismantled
during the Dark Ages and in keeping with
his promise when his people returned to
his law He restored to them the
prophetic gift as a means of furthering
his truth in the world behold I will
send Elijah the prophet My Messenger
now question
at the end of the 2300 days in 1844
that's when the prophecy comes to an end
was the truth
at that time beginning to be restored
did something happen
to restore the truth what was it
no miller Right Movement was before that
right what was it in 1844 what resulted
in 1844 from the millerite movement
yeah but what was the what was the
result where do we find the Fulfillment
the Bible said in at the end of the 2300
days the truth would be restored
where is it
is The Seventh-Day Adventist Church
who else is restoring the Lost truth the
cast down truth who else is doing it
name me somebody
brothers and sisters this is the this is
why 1844 is so essential to us it's not
just saying that Jesus entered into a
place in heaven but in corresponding
with the work in heaven Christ has risen
up a movement on the earth to restore
the truth
and when God rose up a movement to
restore the truth and those people were
seeking to do the will of God what has
God always done to guide his people who
willingly sought to follow him
he's sent a prophet
so that if God's people would begin to
restore the truth in 1844 if God would
raise up a movement what would you
expect to show up at the same time
God said
in the great and Dreadful day
but right before the Grateful Dead great
and Dreadful day of the Lord
he would send Elijah the prophet
right
where's the Fulfillment of that
messenger
listen to what it says here from Loma
Linda messages Pages 33 and 34.
the law of God and the spirit of
Prophecy go hand in hand to guide and
counsel the church we've just seen that
from the scripture
and whenever the church has recognized
this by obeying his law the spirit of
Prophecy has been sent to guide her in
the way of Truth
this prophecy points out clearly that
the remnant church WIll acknowledge God
in his law
and will have the prophetic gift
obedience to the law of God and the
spirit of Prophecy has always
distinguished the true people of God and
the test is usually given on present
manifestations all she's saying there is
the test is usually given obviously we
don't test Paul anymore
but a present manifestation of the gift
will test because it's not in the Canon
of scripture same with Jeremiah's day
same with Daniel's day
as the third Angel's message arose in
the world which is to reveal the law of
God to the church in its fullness and
Power
the prophetic gift was also what
immediately restored uh where was it
restored
how was it immediately restored
where's the Fulfillment
in this church where
if it isn't in Ellen White Brothers and
Sisters it didn't happen
the word of God has failed
you follow that
she says the gift was immediately
restored this gift has acted a very
prominent part in the development and
carrying forward of this message and
we've seen that
now I like especially these next two
statements first selected messages Pages
31 and 32 what does she say some have
stumbled over the fact that I said I did
not claim to be a prophet there was a
time Ellen White got up in front of the
Battle Creek Tabernacle preached a
sermon and said that she was not a
prophet
A.T Jones at the time working with Dr
Kellogg and on his way out
picked up on this and made all kinds of
to do about it well Ellen White claims
she's not a prophet the local newspaper
the hell am I see she's not a prophet
so now Ellen White had to go back and
clarify what she meant
she says here in this passage
why is this she said some some have
stumbled over the fact that I had not
claimed to be a prophet and they've
asked why is this I have no claims to
make only that I am instructed what does
that mean who's instructed her
that I am the Lord's
messenger interesting isn't it why a
messenger behold My Messenger who will
prepare the way before me who's
preparing the who prepared the way for
Christ's first coming
who's preparing the way for Christ's
Second Coming
Ellen White and they have that movement
amen who else
everybody else is looking for a secret
rapture
brothers and sisters we are the only
other Church in Bible mentioned and
pointed out by name
as it were
as a fulfillment of Prophecy
this church is a movement of Prophecy
the other one is the Roman Catholic
Church the two contending Powers at the
End of Time the rest are called Babylon
we are here with a prophetic mission
and God prophesied that he would raise
up a prophet in the last days behold I
send my messenger
Ellen White says I'm instructed by God
that I'm a messenger and this next
statement notice what she says early in
my youth I was asked several times are
you a prophet I have ever responded I am
the Lord's what
messenger I know that many have called
me a prophet but I have no claim to this
time I've made no claim to this title
My Savior declared me to be his what
messenger
his messenger behold I will send my
Messenger to pair the way before
My Savior declared me to be his
messenger why have I not claimed to be a
prophet because in these days many who
boldly claim that their prophets are a
reproach to the cause of Christ and
notice the last piece and because my
work includes what
much more than the word Prophet
signifies and what did Jesus say of John
the Baptist
Prophet he's more than a prophet
Prophet she's more than a prophet
a lesser Light reading leading to the
greater light yes
God's messenger yes
a fulfillment of Prophecy the law and
the prophets that had been cast down as
soon as God's people had set their heart
to seek the will of God and obey the law
of God as that movement rose up
in accordance with what the Prophecies
of Daniel had said God rose up a prophet
to finish the work
thank you
if you will receive it
if you will receive it brothers and
sisters
this is the Elijah who has to come
this is the Elijah who was to come
and I hope you receive it
amen